i'm joined by sir richard barron for
analysis of exactly where this war is at
on day eight serenity thank you so much
for being with us so the russians are
still massed various points around
ukraine this is now
my understanding uh battle two battles
north and south so we've seen unfold
over the last uh ten days or so two
separate but synchronized operations in
in the south an operation designed to
link russia to crimea and to isolate
ukraine from the sea and in the north a
separate operation focused on the
capital kiev and we believe the
objective of that is to is regime change
yeah and let's focus in then if we can
on that fight for the south now we've
just heard from the city of coast and we
understand it has now changed hands if
we look at the map of the south here we
can see uh in more detail exactly how
the russians have begun their advance
pushing out from crimea and taking that
strategic city of coast and explain to
us why that city is so important and why
the city of mariopol is so interesting
at the moment has been contested so
we've seen russian forces mostly coming
out of crimea and they have turned both
east and west
the group that has turned east is
advancing towards the donbass and is
about to link up in mario poll with
russian forces that have come from
russia that establishes contiguous
territory between russia and crimea and
isolates ukraine from the sea of azov in
in the west the forces that have now
arrived at curson which remember that
curson supplies all the fresh water to
crimea and we assess
that that operation will continue round
the coast towards odessa and we're
likely to see unfold
an attack on odessa from the coast and
also from the sea using amphibious
shipping if that is successful it will
have separated ukraine from the sea and
that is a crippling blow to the
ukrainian economy yeah and obviously
that fight for odessa will be coming but
the fight for and we heard from kirsten
just a moment ago a gentleman there in
his apartment there is a fight for mario
paul so ukrainian forces are still in
those areas as we understand it right
now so we would expect to see two things
one as the the battle unfolds for these
cities some parts of the ukrainian
military to fall back to the next
defensive line which in the west would
probably be odessa but the local forces
to remain and they'll probably
transition from opposing the arrival of
russian forces to mounting a serious
insurgency within the confines of that
city okay well that's the fight for the
south let's take a look at the fight for
the north uh sir richard and as we've
been talking about for the past few days
there is this encroaching russian convoy
that's coming down towards kiev um it
appears to have been bogged down let's
discuss why that may well have happened
it's been about three days that we've
known that it's there and it's still
there
so it's been a surprise that convoy has
been stuck for three days but we think
we know why this is first of all there's
been significant ukrainian opposition to
its movement but much more than that
there has been major logistic failures
in the russian forces
probably
a collapse or a fracturing of command
and control but we absolutely need to
keep our eye on that convoy because as
it unsticks itself which we must expect
it to it will arrive on the north and
west of kiev and may start to be part of
the encirclement and as you're showing
here
more obviously today russian forces
approaching from the northeast to begin
to complete an attempt to encircle kiev
now that's obviously the fight the
military aspect of this but there is a
unfolding humanitarian aspect that jane
has been bringing us from the polish
border and there have been calls for
humanitarian corridors to be brought in
now that how those humanitarian
corridors work sir richard
so
we should look at the humanitarian
issues from two directions first of all
there are a lot of ukrainians that are
trying to move from ukraine into
sanctuary in the european union
and and they require safe passage and so
far a million people have made this and
we're expecting rather more to move but
then for the people who are still in
ukraine who are uh being subjected to
the the effects of war
they find that they are beginning to
lose power and water particularly in the
cities and run out of food and medicine
so that is going to become more and more
dire so
one aspect of this is humanity going to
come from the west into these cities
in which case that requires the consent
of russia to allow that humanitarian
access or is russia going to provide
that humanitarian aid as as part of its
uh let's feel better about this
operation that will probably unfold yes
so anything coming over to the east will
need the consent of russia and of course
that's not absolutely well at this
moment okay so richard thank you very
much for that analysis